so if he runs in 2024  um  and he loses do you think it'll also be  stolen again  it could be possibly but there's no way  to  say that it will be or won't be  and how will you tell if it is or is it  like do you think he could just lose  fair and square yeah he could very  possibly but i mean  we feel this last election was rigged  and  that there are a lot of unknown voters  that have passed and how do you vote if  you're dead  you're saying people use the names of  dead voters yes to vote even though that  hasn't been  shown on any of the court cases or  anything  but research from who i'm not exactly  sure i mean i'd have to ask the person  who told me this and he is not with us  today